how long into the industry before you
start to think
I've pushed away all these people that I
love and I'm not happy and I
how how long is that time period yeah so
for me
um I think like to revisit a question
you asked earlier you said can you make
money in this industry for me I you know
someone who I grew up not having a
father in my home yet the father
um he was in the same town grew up in a
very small town in South Carolina and
the added Dynamic was I saw him I knew
he was my father but he was never a
father in my home or my life did he
acknowledge that you were his son uh yes
but but that but that was it there was
no um there was like a few attempts and
um
yeah so there was a few attempts for him
to to be part of my life in some
capacity but he ended up getting married
and then you know you know he was they
were both 16 at the time and my mom
chose to keep me and he chose to you
know continue living his life
and I would see him
and that made me feel what's wrong with
me yeah but like it was confusing at
first and then it made me angry
specifically because I saw this man in
this healthy Dynamic like he like he was
married and they had kids and they had a
nice home and you know they had all
these things and it was just me and my
mom struggling wow most people who grew
up without a father I mean what do I
know I just I guess in my imagination of
this the father is on the other side of
the world before I was just not there I
imagine it's much much harder if you see
this guy and you see his new family yeah
I mean there's there's definitely
different aspects of fatherlessness
where it's like some you know someone in
my case or like there's a there's
there's various you know traumas that
come with levels of fatherlessness like
divorce or maybe some a father that's in
the home but he's not present but
there's but yes to your point it was
very frustrating that the thing that I
felt like I needed most and the thing
that I wanted most was in Arm's Reach
but had no interest in me were you aware
of this at the time or you were just
angry and you didn't know why well I I
was confused until I was angry and but I
was always aware
you know because he was there right you
know so that caused so me having a high
achiever personality it's like well I
can outwork
my feeling of lack I can overcome my
feeling of worthlessness or my need to
be valuable so through affirmation it
was you know first it was Scholastics
then it was Sports then it was getting
the girl that no one else could get then
getting the most girls and so on and so
on but being in that industry that
personality trait came with me both me
feeling inadequate and me feeling like I
need to prove myself right so being
someone who's someone analytical I love
statistics and it's like okay just I'm
tracking literally on a spreadsheet once
I make a million dollars then I'll be
happy I'll be fulfilled it's like so I'm
like tracking it like it's some kind of
game I do it I make a million dollars
and guess what it didn't work and then
the same thing like in the industry I
got nominated for uh performer of the
Year got nominated three years in a row
didn't win didn't win didn't win fourth
year I won it and I thought like that
was like the Mount Rushmore of porn
because it was this big award show and
then it was not only the the actors and
the actresses but the you know the
organizations the studios like they
voted on it so it meant like you're the
guy
and I won and when I won I thought that
it would bring me the sense of relief
this this this feeling of lack this
frustration this pain I thought I would
experience joy and fulfillment and I did
for a second
and it but it didn't work it didn't last
and that quickly Amplified my anxiety
deep in my depression it took me to a
place where decision after decision
after decision led me to a I okay I'm
now making a plan to take my life
so at that point you are truly the dog
who catches the car there is nowhere
else for you to go yeah you've made a
lot of money you're the number one guy
there isn't there is no achievement to
get right in this line of work right
I never got into video games except for
a little period of time yeah when I was
like five years old I played Donkey Kong
and then when I was a teenager I got a
kick out of Grand Theft Auto oh yeah
because it was so crazy it was so you
know you just keep running people over
and yeah flying helicopters into
buildings doing all this crazy stuff
yeah and
I remember though playing the video game
in this aimless way not on the missions
just aimlessly shooting people or
whatever robbing things yeah
and after a certain point
I realized this was pointless
and I just go kill myself in the game
and I fought back on that at some point
over the years
and I think there's something profound
in that
intuition that if you're aimless
and you're just doing things for
pleasure and then you reach what would
appear to be the maximum amount of
pleasure
I've never
considered ending my life right
but I think intellectually I could see
how someone could get to that place yeah
and you get to that place yeah
yeah I literally got to a place where so
I it's interesting so I just came from
uh I was doing a speaking engagement in
Atlanta and
um it was the first time I've been back
to Atlanta since the last time I left
Atlanta the last time I left Atlanta was
11 years ago and that's what I had done
my last film you did the a porn film in
Atlanta in Atlanta okay 11 years ago
and then I'm flying back to LAX and in
my head I'm like making the decision
like okay I'm going to take my life when
I get home go home I get enough I do
some some research I'm saying how much
you know these pain medications like
what I have to take to overdose
I get it I line them up on the counter
I'm like okay I can't swallow this many
pills at once but so this and then I've
got this check in my pocket and it's
just like it's just driving me crazy
it's this giant like cashier's check I
just feel it in my pocket I'm wearing
slacks and I just feel it against my
skin it's driving me crazy I'm not sure
why I'm so aware of it and then I take
it out and I start thinking like well if
I'm going to do this
um you know I assume my bank account
will go to my mom or my brother or
something like that so I'll go deposit
this check and then I'll come back and
take care of this and I welcome to this
bank and normally I would just go to the
Dropbox or the ATM because on the memo
of the check it said what was for like
it would have the title the movie which
was always grotesque and I was
humiliated I didn't want to look someone
in the eye and say hey here's the check
for me selling myself for sex didn't
want to do that but today on on this day
I didn't care I was like whatever I
don't care I went through the line you
know signed the check slide slide the
check across the counter normal
transaction and I pivot to walk away and
she kind of stops me and she says excuse
me Joshua
are you okay
Joshua can I do something for you
and what she didn't know is it had been
over a year since I had heard my name
I'd stop answering my mom's text I'd
gotten rid of like I've unfriended
anyone that followed me on social media
that was like from my actual life my
fraternity Brothers my friends from high
school my brother I wasn't returning any
text I wasn't returning any calls the
only person that it existed was my stage
name which everyone on set called me
everyone knew me I was very well known
so the gym that I went to the barber
shop that I went to like everywhere that
I went that's all that I heard Joshua
did not exist but when she said my name
stopped me in my tracks and it wrecked
me
because all of a sudden I was faced with
what was real
because at that moment I'd created this
plausible reality based on lies guilt
and shame
up to and including if the stage name
guy kills himself well who cares he's
just he's not real yeah but if Joshua
kills himself yeah Joshua was a kid
Joshua has a mom Joshua is pissed off at
his dad Joshua has a brother yeah
so for me I like what I felt immediately
was guilt and regret from not letting my
mom know if I was okay like that was the
last few text messages that she sent me
she's like you know dang it just tell me
if you're okay or not like if you're not
going to come home if you're going to
stay doing them whatever you're doing
whatever I just want to know if you're
okay and I was so selfish
and so caught up in my shame and my
pride that I couldn't even pick up the
phone or send a text and let my mom know
that I was alive
and in that moment when I heard my name
that my mom had given me
my reality was challenged and I felt the
pain that I was numb to
so I ran home and I called my mom
and then my mom said what she had been
saying for you know I'd been in La for
eight nine years something like that but
I was in the industry for six and she
said the same thing she had said I love
you
you're better than this
please come home
so I did so that day I called my agent I
called my PR person quit I quit I quit
I'm out of here I even like found
someone to sublease my place I'm like I
don't care you know just pay rent you
can literally have everything in my home
like all my furniture everything I'm
gonna take some clothes
and I'm I'm out of here there's this odd
paradox
on the one hand you're behaving in this
extremely selfish way on the other hand
you've completely
neglected yourself and denied the
existence of yourself yeah
I say it's a paradox because I don't
think it's it's exactly a contradiction
or an impossibility in fact very often
that would appear to be how these things
go killing yourself is both extremely
selfish and a complete rejection of the
self how does
how is that yeah it it's it's an
interesting thing to struggle with
because on the outside aesthetically you
know I was taking very good care of
myself but I was dying inside and I
think you know that's that's why it's so
much easier to put on a mask and pretend
you know for me I just wanted the person
in front of me to like me or to do the
thing to get the affirmation I didn't
care about anything else but I was a
dissolution and disconnected from
reality the power of the name is so
striking yeah because we think oh who
cares about a name you can have a
nickname you can change your name it's
no big deal that's just words words
words we call that you know I call this
a glass but I could call this a
parakeet wouldn't right it's just
whatever it's just whatever it is
but that isn't true names do matter
quite a lot yeah the first charge given
to Adam in the Garden of Eden is name
everything yeah all the way up to modern
day this big political fight that
everybody seems to be in right now over
transgenderism right is basically a
fight over names yeah and the
relationship between names and reality
if you call me
Johnny or you call me Mary Sue it's not
gonna if you call me Rachel maddowell
I'll probably laugh
but if you say that to someone
who is in the transgender movement sure
the person will lose it if you
mispronounce or misgender meaning use
the correct pronouns for somebody this
is the worst crime you can possibly
commit against them because they know
the power of a name I mean even the the
transgender transition
is a kind of ritual suicide right where
you say okay my old self that's my dead
name that's a dead person I forget that
person yeah I'm this new person
it's hard not to see a parallel to what
you're describing in the industry sure
sure and and that and I think in in a
deeper way in any aspect it's like it's
an identity crisis yeah if my identity
is rooted in a belief around a feeling
or a behavior and I'd identify myself
based on that yeah I'm going to
constantly be in this identity crisis
because there's actually an author of
life that's given me an identity that I
I don't get to choose
who or what I am
but I can feel a certain way but my
feelings can't Define me
because I've already been defined by an
author
I I was talking to a Exorcist on this
show actually
and we were talking about selling your
soul to the devil
and he said well you know you can't
actually do that right that's what do
you mean you can't do that he says you
don't own your soul yeah it's not yours
you know you didn't make your own life
you didn't you didn't craft your soul
and so you can't sell it either the
devil tricks you makes you think you can
salvage you actually can't sell it you
you can't
totally Define yourself we tried to do
that a lot sure but you can't you didn't
choose how you came into this world you
damn well sure shouldn't choose how you
go out of the world right and so you
have obligations to other people and so
this bank teller
providentially yeah calls out says your
name yeah this hits you you call your
actual mother not your invented personas
right yeah I tell my mom and then and
then I run home and uh and then I spend
two years
just doing everything I can to cover up
what I'd done like I literally I had
tattoos cover them up with new tattoos
you know shaved my head deleted my
social media did everything that I could
to hide what I'd done like like very
like genesis 2 Genesis 3. right I'm
running I'm hiding I don't want to be
found and
um I get to a place where
I just I'm okay like I look like I'm
okay on the outside I start working at a
gym and again that the personality
trait's still there it's like what like
that's just who I am like regardless of
what I'm doing if I'm eating wings I'm
gonna eat the most or the hottest like
I'm gonna win I'm gonna die to win no
matter what it's just who I am so it's
like okay if I'm gonna be a personal
trainer I'm I'm going to be the best
thing personal trainer there's ever been
yeah and I've quickly worked my way up
in this gym and you know worked my way
into management and I'm doing okay
but at night I'm not doing okay because
the reality of what's on the internet
and people recognizing me and me just
wanting to be a regular person was
nearly impossible but I was almost in
denial of that